[Music]
I'm stuck in over clouds
hey everybody is Charlie DC posted a
nice shiny HD version of the birds of
prey trailer and English language so
there's actually a whole bunch of new
details that we've got since I did my
last video so we'll break it down and
even though it's technically not DC
there's a really cool Avatar The Last
Airbender Easter egg inside this movie
that I'll explain during the video some
of you might know what I'm talking about
already we're doing a movie take a
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Harley Quinn moment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this we
also got some more information about
Jared Leto's Joker's involvement in this
because this is spinning out of the
Suicide Squad continuity it's the same
version of Harley Quinn just after the
events of Suicide Squad and justice
league there was a big question about
what was going on with Jared Leto
because they have the Joaquin Phoenix
Joker movie which is blowing up big time
even though it's not connected to the
other DC EU films but birds of prey is
in clarification a lot of you be excited
by this it will be rated R just like the
Joker there was a source I was quoting
they said it was gonna be pg-13
apparently that was wrong no worries the
movie will be rated R and that is the
reason why Harley Quinn drops in f-bomb
during that trailer that's why they
attached the trailer to it chapter 2
because that's rated R and released it
in the way that they did because they
didn't post it like they would post a
normal trailer I think just to hype up
the fact that it is way more hardcore
than a normal pg-13 movie but also there
are weird rules about the way you can
market rated r films you have to put a
special red band trailer in front of
them and they haven't been posting as
many red band trailers on YouTube the
last couple of years as they used to so
when you go see the it chapter 2 movie
this weekend what happens is is normally
before films they play the trailers just
like they would for any other movie but
what happens is all the trailers play
then the theater credits for whatever
theater you're going to AMC or whatever
big theater chain those role usually
after that in the United States at least
the actual movie starts playing but what
happens when you go to see it chapter 2
this weekend is that when that happens
when the actual movie begins you get
this fake out trailer that's made to
look like the opening sequence from it
chapter 2 the Warner Brothers logo pops
up the creepy theme song for penny wise
starts playing giving you crazy
flashbacks
red balloons start floating up the thing
that gives it away though is when the DC
logo flashes because you're like wait a
minute when de DC Comics start making
Stephen King movies this is crazy and
then of course like you see this shadow
walking through the balloons it looks
like it's wearing a clown outfit like
penny wise and then now that we have a
nice HD version you can clearly see
Harley Quinn swing her mallet from the
comics to blow up the balloons and say
I'm so F and done with clowns dropping
an f-bomb doesn't seem like that big a
deal but it's been a while since we've
had a more hardcore DC movie you get a
much clearer shot of Huntress riding her
motorcycle speeding through the city I
love HD / potato footage any day it
makes it so much easier to actually pick
out details during trailers you get a
better shot of her whipping her hood off
using her hand-held crossbow she's the
Helena Bertinelli version of Huntress so
she comes from a crime family so this
way them going up against black mask in
the mops of Gotham is so close to her
because she does this all the time on
her own anyway
mary elizabeth winstead looks great as
the character if you didn't watch her
while they were actually filming the
movie last year she got super jacked for
this all of them go off the chain during
the movie at various points that's what
you see all the blood splatters and
that's why they're doing it rated R so
they can actually take it that far with
the fights
Huntress during the movie supposedly
used to work for black masks and is
actually looking to get revenge on
Victor Zsasz so even though black mask
is technically the big villain of the
film there's a lot of other rivalries
going on within his organization makes
sense if you're gonna cast someone as
notable as Christmas and know that you
give him a bigger storyline you get a
much better shot of Ewan McGregor's
black mask inside his nightclub if you
look behind him because we have the HD
version and we can see what's going on
in the background this person with a
white hair looking in the other
direction is actually Christmas and as
Victor Zsasz there been a bunch of
different versions of the character in
the movies so far the most recent
version we saw was on the Gotham TV show
for a couple seasons he's sort of the
enforcer to black masks boss of bosses
here to think of black masks during this
movie is being more like a Sal Maroni a
bigger boss that everyone is afraid of
but Gotham itself is huge that's how
they can have this movie and all this
stuff going on without Batman
necessarily getting involved but
supposedly there is a lot of Batman
mentioned during the movie
he's not supposed to have a cameo or
anything like that if you're wondering
because of all the logistics with the
Robert Pattinson Matt Reeves Batman
movies that are supposed to be set
during the 90s this is set during
present day as far as we know Ben
Affleck isn't coming back to do any more
Batman scenes in present day so if they
wanted to use Batman in the birds of
prey movie they would have to do a
Shazam style twist where they use a
stunt double wearing the costume just
walking into frame and you never see his
face uh-huh
I've added another friend I hope that's
okay
[Music]
in wallet worked for the Shazam movie
ending I feel like you can't do that too
many times before the audience starts to
wise up and it starts to feel like a
really old thing like oh not again why
don't you just show his face you see a
black Canary's singing behind him she's
a songstress just like she was during
the new 52 comics they haven't explained
if she's gonna be a metahuman during
this but I wouldn't be surprised if she
was because we're coming from the
Suicide Squad continuity and we had
metahumans during that movie so it's not
unusual for people to actually have
powers in this world a much better shot
of Cassandra Cain hiding from the
mobsters inside this giant fund house
fight on amusment mile there's a whole
bunch of the movie takes place on
amusement mile because Harley Quinn is
technically the main character in the
movie and so much of this movie is about
her breaking away from the Joker so of
course there's gonna be a couple huge
action scenes in her most cave stuff
you're talking about hero's journey in
amusement mild that would be her
innermost cape you literally walk into
the mouth of a clown thinking about the
Joker we also found out what's going on
here during the fight she throws her
mallet at this person wearing the mask
that's actually one of blackmask
henchmen it seems like they're doing the
false face society from the new 52
comics they're basically an organization
that's started by black masks that wear
a bunch of different masks there's a
white mask there's a black mask is sort
of a court eval situation where they all
try to hide their identities even though
it's not tied to the court of owls or
anything like that and even though it
doesn't show up in this trailer we have
seen pictures of you and McGregor
wearing a black mask but it only covers
the top half of his face it's not the
full black mask that you see during the
Arkham games so he does wear a black
mask during the movie it as for how they
handled the actual Joker during
movie because it's supposed to be Jared
Leto's version of the Joker there
supposed to be some Joker scenes where
you don't directly see his face on
screen just taken from footage that they
shot for Suicide Squad that wound up on
the cutting room floor there were
shelves and shelves of hard drives worth
of digital footage that they shot with
Jared Leto's Joker that didn't make it
into the final cut of the film if you
hear any of the interviews that he did
around that time he actually said he was
really upset because he was only in the
movie for about 10-15 minutes and he
actually shot a couple hours worth of
footage but all that stuff takes place
at the beginning of the movie she leaves
him that's when they pick up with the
birds of prey plot so it's relatively
minor involvement from actual Jay Leno
Joker they see Harley Quinn in the
shopping cart eating the sandwich with
one of her twin laughing hyenas bud and
Lou are in the movie you can actually
see her in this behind-the-scenes
picture wheeling out a whole bunch of
dog feed to give to them there was a
report saying that Harley Quinn would be
narrating some of the movie Deadpool
style breaking the fourth wall
imagine it being more like the first
Deadpool movie than Deadpool - that's
when it comes time to licking wounds
there's no place like home
but in all the descriptions there's no
mention made of Cassandra Kane's parents
her mother is Lady Shiva and her father
is David Kane two of the world's
deadliest assassins so she comes from a
really terrible background supposedly
they're trying to turn her into another
weapon during this movie and that's part
of the reason why Harley Quinn and the
birds of prey want to rescue her from
black mass organization they don't want
her to be indoctrinated into the false
faith society just to become another one
of his puppets in fun fact if you're a
big Avatar The Last Airbender fan the
little girl that's playing Ellijay Bosco
is the niece of Dante Bosco in real life
Prince Zuko from Avatar The Last
Airbender and he was Prince Rufio most
people either quote him as Rufio or
Prince Zuko when you spot him on the
street speaking of which I actually just
did an avatar the last airbender video a
little while ago there's a Netflix
series that they're doing it's gonna be
a retelling of the original avatar the
last airbender story but it's not gonna
premiere til either late next year or
early 2021
not really DC related but I know a lot
of you are hardcore avatar the last
airbender fans
Titans episode 1 just drop they
introduced their new Deathstroke in
their new Batman so I might do a video
for that this weekend but there's a
whole bunch of other stuff leave your
video requests and your big questions in
the comments below
congratulations des Rotom you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everybody click here to watch Robert
Pattinson break down the teaser for the
new Batman movie and click here for my
breakdown of the Avengers what if
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]